begin with that breaking news this
morning that a police officer has been
killed at croydon police station in
south london
the officer was shot dead by a 23 year
old man who was being detained at the
custody center
in windmill lane while the met police
has
issued a statement saying a murder
investigation has been launched
following the death of a police officer
in south london at approximately 2 15
a.m this morning the officer was shot by
a man who was being detained
at croydon custody center in windmill
lane officers and paramedics
treated him at the scene and he was
taken to hospital by london
ambulance service very tragically he
subsequently died
at hospital we are in the process of
informing all of the officers family
and are supporting them with specialist
officers
and the mets statement goes on to say a
23 year old man was detained by officers
at the scene he was also taken to
hospital with a gunshot wound
and remains in a critical condition no
police firearms were discharged
during the incident well for the very
latest we're now joined by our home
affairs correspondent
mark white so mark what can you tell us
well ian obviously this incident
unfolded very quickly that last line in
the statement saying
that no police firearms were involved an
indication of how quickly
the incident uh unfolded we understand
that it was
a prisoner who was being brought to this
custody suite
23 year old man who is now in hospital
in a critical condition who opened fire
on this police officer now in terms of
the
officer himself he died at the scene
despite the efforts of
these medical teams to save his life
the suspect the 23 year old man
is now under police guard in hospital
at the moment and there are obviously
questions
to be answered about whether this
individual when he was brought to this
custody suite
had been properly checked before he was
put in the back of that police van
to be transported to the custody suite
that will
form part of the investigation going
forward for the moment
uh people are just absorbing the the
shocking nature of what happened
we've had a statement through from the
home secretary
pretty patel and that statement she says
i am deeply shocked and saddened to
learn that a metropolitan police officer
has been shot and killed in the line of
duty she goes on to say
my thoughts today are with his family
friends and policing colleagues in
london
and across the country this morning i
spoke to metropolitan police
commissioner
cressida dick to express my condolences
and to offer whatever support is needed
at this trad
as this tragic event is investigated she
goes on to say
this is a sad day for our country and
another terrible reminder of how our
police officers
put themselves in danger each and every
day to keep the rest of us
safe now we've also had a statement
through from
the labour leader secure stammer in that
statement
he said horrific to hear of a police
officer being shot and killed
in croydon our police put themselves in
harm's way
every day to keep us safe all my
thoughts
are with the officers family friends
and colleagues we also have
an mp's reaction sarah jones uh local mp
saying that she is
absolutely shocked as well at the news
and said that she's speaking to the
police
on the details of this awful incident
and my thoughts she says
are with the family and colleagues of
the officer
that was killed so the reaction coming
in there right across the political
spectrum
uh to what is thankfully a very rare
um instance in terms of the the number
of officers who are killed in the line
of duty
everyone will remember uh just over a
year ago pc andrew harper
a thames valley police officer killed
dragged to his death by
three teenagers who were subsequently
convicted
of the killing of that officer well as i
say
thankfully these events are rare and
because of the rarity of these events
they are all the more shocking
but we should say that assaults against
the police are not rari and they have
been
rising at an alarming rate uh in recent
months and years
uh the latest figures out again showing
thousands of officers
across the country are assaulted going
about their daily task of keeping the
public safe
out there on duty subs you know
subjected uh to assault some of them
really quite serious in nature all right
mark thanks for that for now
well reaction continues to come into
this news uh
the prime minister boris johnson has
posted a tweet in which he says
my deepest condolences go to the family
friends and colleagues of the police
officer
who was killed in croydon last night we
owe a huge debt to those who risk our
own lives
to keep us safe we've also had a
statement during the last few moments
from the mayor of london sadiq khan in
which he says devastated by this news
my heart goes out to the family of this
brave officer who has paid the ultimate
price for helping to keep londoners safe
tragic incidents like this are terrible
reminders
of the dangers our police officers face
every single day
and the mayor added my thoughts are also
with the entire metropolitan police
family who i know will be deeply
mourning their colleague
at this extremely difficult time i
remain in close contact with the
commissioner
to offer her and our met officers and
staff
my support well we can also tell you
what
uh the policing minister kit malthouse
has been telling the house of commons
during the last hour let's listen to it
the details are still emerging but the
home secretary has spoken
to the commission of the metropolitan
police and offered the help
and support of the home office as the
force
comforts family friend and colleagues
and investigates
this crime we ask our police officers to
do an extraordinary
job the fact that one of them has fallen
in the line of performing that duty is a
tragedy for the entire nation
i know the entire house will offer their
condolences
to his family and friends and colleagues
may he rest in peace
and may justice follow this so that was
the policing minister kit malta speaking
just a few moments ago in the house of
commons here are some live
pictures the latest live pictures that
we can show you of the scene
in croydon